hi everyone matt luigi here and today
i'm going to be doing a little bit of a
different kind of video instead of my
normal lore or analysis video on eldon
ring or thiamesia or what have you i
just want to celebrate and say thank you
for the fact that i've recently hit 50
000 subscribers and in addition to that
my elden ring endings explained video
hit one million views so we can kind of
celebrate both here basically this is
going to be a q a video i asked if
anybody had questions on a community
post and i got a couple answers so i'm
gonna go through most of them a lot of
them are lower questions and fair
warning i'm gonna be doing this off the
dome i do not have an encyclopedia
knowledge of the lore like i'm sure
there are some other uh elden ring
creators that have a more extensive just
like memory of all the lore and the
things in the game and i don't have that
so a lot of the answers might be not
super substantive but this is a
celebration video so that's not the main
point and with that i'm gonna get into
it so let's get started with the first
question is luigi your real name no
luigi is not my real name the uh
gamertag mad luigi or the youtube
channel name comes from just the first
gamertag i made when i was like eight i
played a lot of smash bros i played
luigi in smash i'm a younger brother so
it makes sense i play luigi and i just
went with mad luigi and that stuck
though the full name mad luigi it does
have some phonetic similarity to my name
my actual name is just matt so mad and
matt go together next question thoughts
as to how many lore videos you think
eldon ring has left for you to make
can't speak about any dlc just yet once
you feel you've run out what do you plan
on doing next or what do plan on doing
that insert the little sick sign from my
cemetery shades video
so how many lore videos does elden ring
have left me to make that kind of
depends since i started my lore videos
pretty broad and central kind of the
central figures of the game like morgan
godric ratagon i did radon um the
endings these were all central demigods
gods all big players and then i kind of
moved away from that after i took a
little bit of a break honestly part of
the reason is because motown just does
such a good job with his big
comprehensive videos um and i'm not
making currently hour half long videos
about these main topics so i kind of
went into another path of exploring
other kinds of things like my recent
videos about some of the very hard to
find lore enemies in the game and there
are more of those so in terms of
answering the question how many lore
videos i can't say i could uh do two
more and be like okay i want to
transition or i could do
15 more and they're just interspersed
with other kinds of content i don't
think i'm going to be doing 15 lore
videos straight obviously the dlc will
have a lot more lore videos in store
because the dlc should expand on the
lore in a good amount of ways or expand
on one area of the lore but there are
probably a handful of other low amounts
of lore enemies that i kind of want to
highlight like one comment mentioned the
raven mountain assassin so that could be
something i do a lore video on and also
i do want to do other kinds of videos um
maybe after i'm done with all the lore
videos but also currently like i want to
do a pretty comprehensive critique of
elden ring or at least the biggest issue
i have with it and i think that'll come
up in another comment so i'll save on
that but also things like more of the
philosophy and themes um like my one
philosophy video i was really really
happy with that the frenzy flame and
nietzsche so i'd like to do more of that
like the central philosophy of the game
um about how
we must struggle and how that's kind of
been the overarching mantra of the frame
soft games in general um is to persevere
and to
life is worth it through that
perseverance through the struggle
despite the horrors and the darkness
that we see in these games um just like
we see in life and i think that's a very
central theme and it's shown in a lot of
ways in the game so i'd like to do a
philosophy video in general on that and
looking at other aspects in the game
that show philosophical elements and
also how games and philosophy interact
how games are a unique art form and the
philosophy of aesthetics in relation to
games so yeah a lot of philosophy i'd
like to do more general game analysis on
elden ring and then maybe some other
games as well and that connects with the
philosophy and how certain games really
use the fact they're a game really well
like dark souls did that really well and
somewhat by extension the rest of the
series but it's most explicitly done
with dark souls 1 with halloween and
death and i covered that in one small
video back in the day but there's also
knee automata or automata and soma is
another good one that does that uh
celeste i think kind of does it maybe
outer wilds eg matthew or the guy that
did the one of the elden ring boss
critiques he has a outer wild video i
think that's going to release soon that
is covering that so excited to see that
and yeah that's basically um some of
what else i'm gonna cover on the channel
i want to do more lore want to do
philosophy themes philosophy of games
and philosophy in elden ring okay next
up so what's the lore reason for rolling
making you invincible and is there an
outer god of rowling i should know about
so there probably is not an outer god of
rolling unfortunately but there are some
items that reference rolling and make
your rolling better they don't give much
lore explanation on it just like in
previous souls games there were rings i
forgot what they were like dark souls 3
they were the white or silver and red
gem rings i don't know what the names
are but i know there are two different
rolling rings in this game i actually
pulled this up there's the crucible
feather talisman which reads improves
the effectiveness of dodge rolls but
increases damage taken at all times and
then it gives some crucible lore nothing
about rolling but it's feathers so it's
an aspect of the crucible and then
there's also one other the windy crystal
tier which i don't know if i ever
actually picked up on a play through the
resulting concoction increases the
effectiveness of dodge rolls for a
certain duration but it doesn't give any
lore that just came from the earth tree
the
previous item the crucible feather
talisman these are both old aspects
crystal tears come from the er tree and
the crucible talismans are obviously
from the crucible so whatever rolling is
is something very old and
maybe just relates to the crucible we
could say it's an aspect of that the
crucible not really an outer god but an
older primordial form of life in the
lands between
next question congrats really have liked
your videos do you think eldon ring
should have been made differently and
how what are the main issues with the
game compared to the other from soft
games i don't know if i would say
necessarily compared to the other
fromsoft games but i know i can speak on
what i think elden rings major flaw is
how it should have been made differently
what are the main issues i think eldon
ring is too big it simply is too big a
lot of the videos that talk about the
issues in melvin ring even the critiques
or the defenses they all describe uh the
issues that come about maybe not always
but it feels like almost always their
issues where they're saying well if
you're gonna have an open world that's
this big and this expansive and open
world and it's so massive and there's so
much content you're gonna have to reuse
bosses you're gonna have to reuse assets
you're gonna have to have enemies in the
ways they are and it's all stuff that i
think is just uh the game should be
smaller the last half the third of the
game is pretty slow uh the mountaintop
of the giants is not a well-done area in
the sense of as some have said it might
have been better just without any
enemies at all as opposed to repurposed
enemies from kaelin i think there is
nearly no if not no new enemies after
you get out of lane dell for the rest of
the game it's just uh there's so many
issues the reuse of bosses and just the
scope of the game introduces so many
things that i think if the game was
smaller just like say 60 to 70 the size
of the current game that time that was
spent making it bigger was just spent on
refining and making the best experience
out of the 60 to 70 that was remaining i
think that would have been a better game
than the elden ring we see here i think
a lot of the issues in the current elden
ring would have been fixed if it was
just a smaller game and it was a more
well
polished in all of the areas that were
kept and that said it could still be a
really massive game 60 to 70 percent of
elden ring is still a massive game
that's longer than any of the previous
fromsoft titles so it can be an open
world it can be big it can be great can
be grand but it could have been better i
think if it was smaller and in a more
dedicated critique video i would talk
about that because that's my central
issue with the game is that it's uh too
big and main issues compared to other
problem solved games yeah it's just it's
too big most of the other farmsoft games
um have aspects or characteristics that
are better done than other ring but also
elder ring has plenty of aspects that
are better done than a lot of those
games but uh yeah so i would say that's
the main issue next question why was our
first mating killed i don't know a good
lore reason but it presents a good place
to start to make the character something
special in the sense of once you first
start the game you notice that there's
an issue you don't have a maiden so you
can't progress normally you have to go
in the game and you meet melana and it
progresses as you are the one to become
the elden lord as opposed to any tarnish
when there are lots of tarnish it's
basically like a kind of inciting moment
it's not something that happens when
you're going around but it serves a
similar purpose in getting the story
going in a special way
next question all right what's with the
ancient dragon god placidus x god um i
actually did bring up the remembrance of
the dragonlord to just explicitly answer
this the dragonlord whose seat lies at
the heart of the storm beyond time is
said to have been elven lord in the age
before the urgery once his god was fled
the lord continued to await its return
this is the fectra i'm reading i don't
have the actual game text open so there
could be something issue there but it's
probably right if there's an issue
someone let me know so that was the
that's what the question is referring to
the ancient dragon god it could be that
the god is the outer god since we know
that's from this item placidus 6 was
said to have been an elden lord so it
could have just been that the greater
will abandon the dragons in favor of
america and godfrey but it also could
have been a god like how america is a
god to
ratagon and godfrey they are the elden
lord and america is their god this god
could have been plasti do sixes
basically just counterpart god that
justifies him as eldon lord and at that
point i don't know if there are any good
theories about what that is there
probably are i don't know them about who
or what that would have been the ancient
dragon god that fled it could just be
something that's expanded on the dlc it
could be something that's never
referenced again just to set up that
this dragon was an ellen lord before to
give more context to the ages of the
earth tree and before the earth tree and
what an elden lord can and can't be this
is evidence that godfrey wasn't the
first elden lord all things considered
um maybe he's the first ellen lord of
the age of the urgery but there were
elven lords before that so shows that
the elden ring probably was operating in
a way before the urgery came about in
its current existence so i don't have a
further answer past that but it does
show some specific things
next up we have some of the longer
questions did the archery just spit down
a bunch of thorny branches to kill all
the giants in one fell swoop the way the
scene is set up and lore bits we find
america sent godfrey and the tarnish to
face off with the giants getting them
all together in one good spot to cast a
devilish spell to wipe them all out er
tree thorn again those guided by grace
of course recycle backing the ur tree
kind of a win-win for the new order if i
ask you or if you ask me
this is a possible theory um we see in
the mountaintop of the giants that lots
of the giants look like they were
probably gutted at once
and if i'm thinking about it very just
off the cuff i haven't thought about
this much at all ever before um it would
make sense that kind of one fell swoop
attack of some kind happens i don't know
if that would have included all of the i
guess people that would become tarnished
they wouldn't be tarnished yet godfrey
and the rest of the golden order that
was attacking the giants that america
would use some sort of spell to get them
all at once it does look like an event
that could have happened all at once
because all the giants are kind of
frozen in time in a moment with their
stomachs gutted probably of the fel god
but yeah so it could be it's a
definitely a possibility though i don't
remember or know enough about the giant
specifically to tell
next i'd love to know what you think of
overall timeline of events that occur
from the falling of the elden beast to
the start of the game as your character
as well as how you think pharamazula
connects to the rest of the game which
could be his own video congrats on the
50k thank you for the congratulations
and a timeline is hard to say i know
quayleigh had a video that was going
through some of the timeline of the game
in the sense of things that corresponded
to timelines in the real world like
mesopotamia and the roman empire and the
rise of christianity and kind of themes
and languages and stuff in the game that
are referencing that kind of thing but
as an overall timeline it would be hard
to say we did talk earlier in this video
just a few minutes ago about how
plastidusix was in eldon lord before the
age of the urgery uh so it definitely
starts with the crucible or the one
great as the frenzy flame likes to say
where everything was kind of one and as
time went on the individuation happened
so things grew out and became individual
aspects
maybe the greater will was the
significant influence in causing that
individuation maybe it was happening to
some degree and the elden ring really
promulgated that more we see the
frenzied plane blaming the greater will
for that for individuation for the end
of the what was the crucible and how it
wants to turn everything back into one
but in terms of specifics it's hard to
say the elden beast and the elder ring
are supposed to have come at the same
time which is probably pretty early on
maybe the crucible was at some state
before that and then the elden beast and
the other ring came and the timeline of
all the events of the game is hard to
say or it's hard to say for me offhand
right now a specific timeline to some
degree can be built but obviously a lot
of things are pretty murky we have the
knocks existing at some point before
they were destroyed by the greater will
and by probably estelle taking away the
sky of the nameless eternal city in the
deep root depths or group depths we have
the
sword monuments that talk about the
different battles and ages and the
shattering for example you don't have a
super clear timeline on the events or
super specifics on a lot of those events
like the first lane dell war i think and
the second landel war uh second one
definitely came after the first so a lot
of the specifics i probably i just can't
answer too well fair missoula we talked
about a little bit in the stoneworm what
what's the name the lookout stones video
seems like the lookout zones were built
from the ruined fragments of pharah
missoula so pharah missoula already
started getting destroyed before those
were built possibly or maybe they were
refurbished with them but phara missoula
being the mausoleum of plasti do six is
very ancient we know placidus is ancient
because he was the elden lord before the
age of the urgery so pharaoh missoula
would have been a probably the oldest in
the game say for the ruins we see in the
grounds of the lands between um but yeah
so not gonna have a clearer picture on
that
next do you think godric's dragon grab
attack is bugged due to the little
amount of damage it does um i haven't
bought godric in a long enough time
while checking the health bar and
getting grabbed by the dragon grab so i
can't say it could have been i maybe got
grabbed in like my first playthrough and
if i would remember i don't think i
would have gotten killed by the uh grab
so maybe the fact that it's a grab and
it's not a one shot means it doesn't do
much damage and maybe people in the
comments maybe you guys watching have
fought godric recently and it does a
really small amount of damage and if
that's the case a grab normally does a
high amount of damage and the animation
for his grab is pretty high damaging um
or looks like a lot of damage it looks
like that's a lot of damage uh so i
would say maybe but i i don't know
next up we have a question i probably
won't be able to answer like at all who
or what do the various statues represent
i assume many are just decorative not
representing anyone in particular but
others not so much like the statues of a
rogue figure holding a gold staff found
all over langdale capital could very
well be godwin uh what about the
sculpture holding crystals found in
rental holes in bellum highway and yeah
there the rest of it keeps going but i
i don't know i don't know most of these
statues by memory i know there are the
statues underground of the
long tall guy with the beard and the
tablets kind of looking like 10
commandments i don't know what those
statues reference i haven't looked into
it there could be something that gives
some evidence about them i know they're
in like mogs i think they're in mog's
mausoleum or mogwin palace i know
they're in like the chauffeur well
rivers or somewhere around there but i
wouldn't be able to say specifically
what they are or what most of the
statues are in the previous video uh my
previous video on the
cemetery shades we did uh learn just a
little bit about rosis who is the usher
of death and rosis is the one who
is the statue that points to catacombs
throughout the lands between the statues
you go up to and click on them and then
they point to a catacomb with like a
yellow not a yellow a blue
light um those are roses i can say that
roses axe describes a little bit about
how roses was the usher of death other
than that i don't know and a follow-up
question also was curious about the
giant waterfall that goes from caled
east of the steel sanction straight up
to mountaintops of the giants just a
feature of the world a result of some
event does that mean some of the other
water features drawn on the map can be
found i don't know what this is
reference to and i don't have the game
open is it saying that this is a feature
on the map or this is a feature just a
waterfall in the actual world um i don't
i don't know uh yeah sorry and finally
we have a very long question for the
final one i'm not gonna read the whole
thing here i'm going to read the actual
question at the end and summarize a
little bit and then i'll answer it as
best i can what do you think about the
lore game as a whole on a thematic level
and then thoughts on these kinds of
ideas uh the ideas presented here are
basically like uh ellen ring being meta
america representing from fans slash
veteran and kinds of ideas about
different roles being represented or
different kinds of people experiencing
the game or creating the game um being
represented by people in the game or
ideas about global politics america
representing america the golden order
representing christianity the golden
order representing christianity there is
definitely some element to that um one
just like a strong religious order um
like the church in bloodborne has
obviously ties to like churches in real
life like elements and thematics of that
obviously plays into the presentation of
it in the game and it does so here like
the quail egg video i mentioned talks
about how aspects of the golden order
kind of mirroring aspects of
christianity and how they develop over
time so there definitely is some of that
though the other kinds of meta
interpretations i don't know
there are plenty of things to interpret
about the games and you can take them in
the direction you will sometimes getting
really really deep in the weeds doesn't
seem the most sensible to me and that
might seem odd coming from somebody who
kind of does that on my channel a lot
but i don't know really really really
really deep speculation never i don't
know i don't i don't seem to super like
it or i don't seem to super think it's
the best way for me to understand things
at least so i don't i wouldn't really
think of america representing the from
fan or veteran or being things being too
meta they can be maybe i'm not a good
judge of when things are meta versus
when they aren't but yeah i think there
are lots of themes that the game does
kind of get meta in the sense of like
when i talked about dark souls 1 and how
games interact and are unique forms of
art and they do so by being interactive
games are distinct because they're
interactive as opposed to movies or
books or what have you and so maybe
there's some meta level there in the
sense of calling the player in and that
using the interactivity with the
narrative of the game to make something
greater maybe that's kind of meta dark
souls does that with halloween and death
and how the player themselves can go
hollow if they give up on the game and
that can lead to their player character
being hollow because the halloween in
the game the player character
experiences isn't uh full halloween they
never go full brainless but they don't
turn into a full hollow unless maybe the
player becomes a hollow and gives up on
the game then eldon ring is kind of an
extension of that like most of the from
saw games in the sense of struggling of
not giving up not falling to the
uh temptation to give up um of how
things are too difficult and
too hard and too dark and to just throw
it all away so maybe there's a meta
aspect there though i'm not super on the
level of getting really deep
speculations of i guess just of another
kind um but maybe this just take
personal bias
and that does it for the questions i had
as uh recording this video and yeah so
thank you very much for everybody who
watched let me know if you have any
thoughts on the game on creating content
on any of my answers here uh if you have
more questions you can maybe leave in
the comments and if they're
straightforward enough i can answer them
in common form and yeah just thanks so
much for everybody who's been with me on
this ride 50 000 is a lot and next year
is going to be the 10-year anniversary
of this channel had many big hiatuses
but i first started making videos on
this channel almost 10 years ago and i
actually started making videos even
before that it's been a long ride and
it's been a very uh exciting ride
definitely once eldon ring stuff has
come out and we've gotten a lot of new
people on the channel there have been so
many haters and channels so old that a
lot of my old-time subscribers probably
just don't exist anymore or they don't
use their accounts or they're not on
youtube
or they've aged out or they subscribed
for minecraft videos in
2014 or whenever i was making videos and
now i'm doing elden ring lore videos in
2022 so they're not watching but thank
you to everyone who has been watching um
i'm gonna keep going definitely shooting
for a hundred thousand subscribers that
is the i guess big goal um but also a
goal is to do this full time 100 000
subscribers would help me get closer to
that and yeah so thank you for watching
thank you for being part of the channel
thank you for supporting my work in any
way you do you can do that by liking and
subscribing of course by becoming a
patron on patreon and even just viewing
the videos commenting your thoughts and
stuff it all helps at all is great and i
i like to see the discussion i really
like to see people enjoying the content
and uh feeling like it's meaningful
stuff i've gotten a lot of really nice
comments um on the 50 000 subscriber
stuff and it was really great to see
people liking my content people thinking
i uh go in depth with stuff and they
really liking the philosophy stuff which
i wasn't sure if people would like since
that's definitely a little bit more
esoteric and
drier academic stuff maybe a little bit
but it is like philosophy of life and
like living and they're really like
powerful stuff that's what i like the
most and that's what i tried to present
in that video and i would want to
present in future videos i do i really
want to do more of that deeper themes
and like kind of the justifying life and
finding the really really good stuff in
art and games um and that they show an
elden ring they show in many areas of
life so i'm rambling um but it's just
all to say thank you and to
reflect and to be at peace and to
have a good time
doing things that i enjoy uh that are
meaningful not just hedonism but also
some meaning in buying so thank you for
watching that probably two or three
times now i hope you'll stick around the
channel look out for more videos and
i'll see you in the next one thanks bye